hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan today I mention the
questions from one of my newsletter
readers Andy Sewell who wrote insane I
have a computer repair shop how can I
grow it so thanks for the question
great question a lot of entrepreneurs
one of the biggest challenges is how do
I grow my business you know you maybe
started it up and you got a few
customers or how do I get it up to that
next step so a couple of ideas for you
the first is partnerships this is the
fastest way to grow your business it's
fine somebody else who's already selling
to your target market who's not selling
the same who's not a competitor so not
selling the same products or services
but complementary products or services
and partner with them and so the easiest
way to look at it is find the people who
are selling the products before they buy
from you so the customers before they
come to you who are they buying from and
so if you're computer repair shop
chances are it's wherever they're buying
their computers from right then that
might be a good potential source look at
anybody who they're buying products or
services from before the bind from you
and then try to find a partnership
agreement with them it could be just
Commission it could be same okay I'll
give you X percent of any deals that
come through it could just be referring
business back and forth to say you know
you'll promote them but they promote you
find some kind of deal that works and if
they really have an established base of
people then if it's one of the fastest
ways to grow any business so I highly
recommend looking at trying to form
local partnerships the second way is if
you're already doing some business you
really have customers coming in really
try to focus on creating an outstanding
customer experience with them
the more customers learn to like you or
love you they trust you they respect you
they listen to your your expert advice
and opinions the more they're going to
come back and tell their friends and
especially with something like computer
repair there's a lot of sketchy people
in that business right there's it's one
of those things where you don't really
know much about the business a lot of
the people who come to you are not
experts they come to you because they
need the help and a lot of them often
get taken advantage of by people in your
position and not saying you do it and
hopefully you don't
but they take they get taken advantage
of and so they're they're afraid to come
in and bring their computers in and so
if you can make it so that they're in a
trusted environment they're really
comfortable you explain things in terms
that they can understand and that they
feel like they're getting really good
service and they're not getting ripped
off they're gonna keep coming back to
you right it's the ones where they feel
like they're getting a bad deal but they
don't really know better so they they go
once and then they never come back
that's not the customer you want yeah
it's it's not worth ripping off your
your customers you want the guys who
feel like they're getting good value for
their money
they understand what the problem is they
see that you can fix it in a really fast
way and so that means they're gonna keep
coming back with computers there's
always only problems so you can get
repeat business from your clients but
you want to create such a good
experience that they tell their friends
and bring them in as well so you want
them to say you know anytime one of
their friends come to them and say hum
I'm really having a hard time with my
computer you want them to say you got to
go see this guy who's the best right so
are you creating that experience yet all
right it's your business so good that
your customers can't wait to go out and
talk about you if you can get repeat
business from your customers and get
them to bringing referrals
that's an awesome way to grow your
business because referred customers buy
more spend more time with you are more
loyal they'll you know easier to
cross-sell or upsell on things and there
were more friends as well so really you
know I'm sure you doing a good job right
now just find ways to make it excellent
right so we always on the tip of the
tongue of your customers and make them
love talking about you and there's
always ways to make that better so
improve your customer experience that's
number two the third way I look at is
try to do some online marketing I don't
know what you're doing right now but
only marketing is one of the most cost
effective ways to grow your business and
so you have a website make sure it's
found in the local listings it's how a
lot of people will start to find the
service like yours they'll go you don't
know what city you're in but you know
I'm in Toronto so if I had a problem a
computer
I might go try no computer repair shop
you know do you show up and so you know
creating an experience online so that
you're showing up in search engines if
you're not showing up yet in the organic
results you can try the paid results
just
start getting some traction momentum
going there but you know invest in a
little bit time effort money into your
online marketing so that when people are
searching for you
you're gonna show up and if you don't
know how to do that then I look at
partnering up with somebody who is an
expert in that or hiring them to help
you with your your online marketing your
SEO because that is how a lot of people
are going to find you and having an SEO
campaign and email marketing campaign
are two of the most cost effective ways
to build a great business so hopefully
that helped again in summary partner up
with people who already are selling to
your target market
create an awesome customer experience
and people want to keep coming back to
you and refer their friends to you and
then also invest some time effort money
into your online marketing so that
people can find you online and hopefully
your coming up at the top of the search
engines so that's my advice for you
hopefully that helped if you guys
enjoyed this video please give it a
thumbs up below those of you who have a
question about your business or a
question with this video feel free to
leave it in the comment section below I
always read those I love seeing those
come in so thank you and I'll see you in
the next episode